hi I'm Regina alcohol hi i'm samuel
l.jackson all buzzfeed and we're gonna
do some okay of course what I like this
one who was your first real friend in
Hollywood and do you still speak what
doesn't mean the first famous person
that you met that is your real no I
don't think just your friend and how I
don't think if they had to be first real
friend in Hollywood we know yes we speak
oh good I'll watch it I'm not just
Denzel anybody you not all mad about her
her being so successfully many do not
first crazy rumor you heard about
yourself do you remember what was it no
tell me what a lot good that my my agent
was stealing money from me oh that I was
gonna leave my agent that I was gonna
get a new age what was you cursing
people out but that's not a woman that's
true maybe first crazy room I heard
myself was gonna he's really a nice guy
[Laughter]
movie kiss are like real kissing in the
world real kiss in the world that lips
are tongue I don't even remember but I
know woo woo woo playing spin the bottle
and just a little girl from up the
street
well I've leaned over to turn my hair
did like that she just grabbed my faces
jabs at tugging my mouth and I was like
oh my god oh no I was like oh this is
what is old Oh
hello boyfriend
oh you're wondering I was 16 those a 16
year old was like a tonka 16 oh wait
before 60 Manila girl suckers on your
mama was she about 19
she was fast yeah I like fast girls
those those a diamond to my grandma on
him really stay with Neto fast fo yeah I
was like which maze what totally made
you go what is today looking Oh first
wife and experience I want to hear yours
it's the first really Wow fan experience
was at Canada we were we were in can for
pulp fiction and we were going to the
party after the movie and these people
were jumped on the car because they were
trying to get john travolt out of the
car and the limo was rocking like that
and i had my best friend from high
school with me Clark
Stacy share was in the car with them and
we were fighting our way through the
crowd to get to him that Stacy was
trying to get out of the car and he kind
of grabbed her and called hacking and me
and Karthik just started knocking people
to power under people get into the towel
to get to the party that's right it was
insane
first my memory that comes to mind when
you're thinking of the shaft set that
means the carafe set or the chef set the
first foot chef set that I was on the
courage after meeting you when I walked
in and you were leaning on
on the thing and he said I'm so glad you
got this job because I was so sick of
the time you saying your name that's
true she did talk to you up in first
funny memory comes to mind when thinking
of the sauce yes it was
why are we shooting in this place when
we could have just done this in New York
in it was home first celebrity crush
now is this celebrity crush what when
you became a celebrity or is this a
celebrity when you were just really
talking about this book for folk folk
you is crushing on when you got here
right Barbara Stanwyck
[Music]
bigger than celebrity first thing you
tell yourself when you feel like giving
up you you you felt like that no fin
assistance I want to be the first person
in Hollywood to to do something first
first time you bombed an audition this
to me first
that first audition I bombed yeah well
we all doesn't it was a movie that never
got me maybe it was me I don't know but
like it was your father movie never got
me I think so
yeah I was I would they were resting all
their hope was
and talent I never discovered what I
know I went to an audition I didn't bomb
but the people I was auditioning with so
oh you mean the group hey whoa oh no and
it was super it was the director and a
producer Reservoir Dogs I read with
Quentin Tarantino and Lawrence bender
the producer they were now look I didn't
realize who they were until I finally
saw the movie later but I was in that
auditioning gone horrible and then you
know I finally saw the movie at Sundance
and that it were and I was like oh well
he did and then he said to me how do you
like to do whoo-hoo I got your part cuz
he remembered me understood
so did he say why you didn't get it you
know he didn't say why I didn't get it
but he made up he wished that Ben and I
told him the movie would've been better
with me in it hey guys we just finished
during our first time to BuzzFeed so now
come see chef in theatres Bret this
weekend bye bye camera
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]